dans le sud est du pays sur la côte
mexicaine du golfe l'état de comme péché
a été le moins touché par la pandémie
c'est ici que des élèves retrouvent
l'école en petits groupes pour maintenir
la distanciation physique
la recommandation est d'avoir quatre
élèves dans chaque salle ici il n'y en
aura que trois quarts c'est en fonction
du nombre d'élèves par classe je vais
les répartir selon les priorités
scolaire de chacun face à des
enseignants vacciner les échos les
portent des masques et des écrans
faciaux en plastique
la durée des cours est néanmoins
raccourcis je suis contente d'aller à
l'école de voir ma maîtresse et mes
copains de classe
[Musique]
je parle un peu sur internet mais je ne
peux pas travailler car le réseau ne
fonctionne pas très bien
des travaux scolaires ont été envoyés
aux écoliers depuis le début de la
pandémie
mais ils sont nombreux à ne pas avoir
d'ordinateur ou d'accès internet à la
maison
ce n'est pas la même chose ici pour nous
nous ne sommes presque jamais à la
maison
nous devons aller aux champs nous devons
travailler nous n'avons pas assez de
temps pour faire court maintenant nous
sommes heureux parce qu'elle va à
l'école pas à plein temps mais elle va
apprendre plus de choses là bas
la campagne de vaccination des
enseignants de cinq autres états ayant
un nombre relativement faible de k2
coronavirus a commencé ce mardi jour
choisi par le président mexicain andres
manuel lopez obrador pour se faire
injecter sa première dose du vaccin
d'oxford astrazeneca